all right we can get started hello
everyone thank you for attending this
webinar i am andrew reinhardt i am the
cto and founder of cedarolabs
let's hop right into it today we're
going to talk about cedero metal
sederal metal is our way of doing
kubernetes on bare metal when we're
going to talk about how you can manage
kubernetes on bare metal and some of the
solutions that we have cooked up and
some of the common issues that you'll
run into
so first of all um
so the server power management is
something that we commonly see
users kind of being apprehensive about
when we're talking about um
you know moving them say onto bare metal
from vms or the cloud or because they
are seriously considering bare metal
and um you know it's a very human
process a human has to figure out
when the machine needs to be turned on
or off and if maybe it is turned off
accidentally
you need to set up alerting and all that
good stuff to make sure
that you are notified
the next issue that we commonly see is
the server lifecycle management which is
things like installing the operating
system
and uninstalling the operating system
and how do you do that in an automated
fashion
we also have the operating system
management itself so you know how do i
configure my operating system
for
kubernetes how do i do user management
patch management upgrades and hardening
and so on and so forth
and then we have kubernetes management
in and of itself being a very large
issue
people are still struggling with that
alone let alone everything else
common things also we see are in
the networking space so node networking
you know how do i configure my node to
be reachable from the outside world
exposing services from kubernetes to the
outside world load balancing services
how do we do this
and then finally storage this is a
a common need when you're running
stateful applications obviously
and so let's just start off with talking
about a few definitions
before we dive into things
first of all sedero comes with the
notion of a server a server
aptly named um it is basically a custom
resource definition in kubernetes that
represents your physical machines this
is something that eventually you'll be
able to do something like kubectl get
servers and see all the servers
registered with the system
and then on top of that we have the
notion of a server class which is
essentially a filter so you have all
these disparate servers how do i group
those servers and treat them as a unit
so for example in aws you have
you know t4s t4 smalls you have t3
larges you have m5 larges so on and so
forth server classes are our way to give
you that same experience but on-prem
and not only that but they also give you
the ability to configure a set of
machines in the exact same way
so for instance if we have a server
class that we know a particular
make and model of server has maybe a
radio a regular sata drive and an nvme
drive we can say
for everything in this server class
install
the operating system to the sata drive
the next thing is there's the notion of
a metal cluster and really what this is
is just a way to declaratively define
what your cluster should look like on
prem specifically in the bare metal
scenario so mapping server classes to
your
cluster definition so that you can
handle this in a very declarative way
then we also have talos linux which is
our
reimagined linux distribution written
from the ground up purpose built for
running kubernetes it is an api driven
operating system so we've removed bash
we've removed ssh
we've removed all traditional access to
the system
it is a 50 megabyte squash fs so
completely read only and it runs
entirely out of ram and so you have a
very simple clean and efficient way to
run an operating system
and not only that but it also manages
kubernetes for you
i should mention that cedaro metal
integrates very tightly with talos linux
so let's talk about
how you would get up and running with
sedero metal in your data center
let's imagine that we have some servers
that have been racked
networking configured
and you walk in with a laptop
the process is going to look like this
we're going to want to create a
kubernetes cluster because cedero metal
requires a kubernetes cluster it runs as
an application on top of kubernetes so
using our talo ctl
cli we can actually provision a
kubernetes cluster right here on our
laptop using docker a very simple
and quick way to get kubernetes running
on this network very quickly
the next thing we're going to do is
we're going to use cluster ctl
which is the cluster api cli
which is the technology that cedero
metal is built on top of to install
cedero metal onto that kubernetes
cluster
it's a simple one line command in most
cases
so at this point we have sedero metal
installed cedero metal is coming with
two different services kubernetes
services one being a udp service and one
being
a tcp service the udp service is for
tftp and the tcp services actually
functions for multiple
things within the cedaro world so
it's going to offer up specifically pixi
ipixi
it's also going to offer up the cedaro
metal api
and it is also going to
expose a way for these machines to get
their configuration files when they
become part of a cluster
and so at this point we need to expose
these services and this is just an
exercise of how do i expose a kubernetes
server
once we do that we turn on a machine
after we've told them you know via dhcp
to boot off of this exposed service
we turn on a machine it pixie boots
sedero metal is going to say i have
never seen this machine before
so let's send back an agent the agent is
then responsible
for
capturing data off of that machine and
submitting it back to sedera metal
sederal metal is going to save this in
the form of a custom resource definition
called a crd
so now within
our laptop based kubernetes system we
could do something like coop ctl get
servers and we can see
all the physical physical attributes
associated with those servers so for
example let's imagine that we have
you know a random set of dell r630s and
some hp proliants
the next thing we're going to want to do
is we're going to have to submit a
server class and
what the server class allows us to do as
i mentioned earlier is it allows us to
filter down all of these disparate
systems
and use the physical data
that we've pulled off from the agent
associated with the server and filter
them into classes
in this case we're going to filter them
down into what we're calling a g1 small
x86 and a g1 medium x86
and i should mention that your decision
on the naming and
what qualifies says this is very
flexible it's completely up to you you
base it on
labels that get associated with attached
to the server or
the physical attributes that are in the
spec of the server definition
so now that we have our
server classes and we have our
kubernetes cluster ready to go
we can now define our cluster as i
mentioned earlier we're going to define
a metal cluster
we're going to push this to
our local laptop we're going to submit
and say
i want a
one node
one control plane node and one worker
node
cluster
in practice you typically want this to
be h so
three nodes and as many for the control
plane and as many workers as you think
you might need
so in this example i'm gonna say
at least in the diagrams i'm gonna say
give me a kubernetes cluster that is
made up of one g1 small x86 and one g1
medium x86
and what cedaro does is it knows how to
choose a server
at random
from these server classes
power them on
knows that it needs to install talos
the whole pixie process gets initiated
talos gets installed once talus is up it
knows how to grab the configuration file
from this management cluster
and now we have a kubernetes cluster
running on bare metal
at this point
we can't have somebody's living in the
data center with a laptop
and so we need to actually take these
management tools and move them onto this
cluster that we just created
essentially what we're doing is we're
pivoting from one cluster to another
we're pushing all the cedaro metal
objects the cluster objects
and sedero metal installation itself
onto this management cluster
so now we can remove the laptop from the
equation and in our data center we have
a management cluster which acts as a
commanding control center for us to
create
as many clusters as we want within this
bare metal
data center going forward
so now that we have our management
cluster i'm just going to run through uh
a quick demo
um of what it would look like to create
a workload cluster
let's take a look at our management
cluster now running in the data center
and now let's see a list of servers that
have been registered with cedaro metal
notice that this server is unallocated
and not currently part of a cluster
let's go ahead and create the cluster
now
and now if we take a look at that server
once more we'll see that it is allocated
this means that it has been chosen to be
part of the cluster we can verify this
by taking a look at the server binding
notice that the server was chosen from a
server class
the cedaro infrastructure provider
represents the physical server to
cluster api in the form of a metal
machine
a metal machine is then mapped to the
standard cluster api machine resource
at this point our cluster should be up
and ready to go
we can see from the cluster status that
our control plane has been initialized
and is now ready and the infrastructure
is also ready
this means that we have successfully
created our cluster on bare metal
okay so just to recap what we've done so
far is we've walked into a data center
we have
bootstrapped our entire management plane
from a laptop
um we've installed sedara metal we've
exposed this pxe service we've
registered servers we've then classified
those servers and in the demo i showed
that how you can use those server
classes in those servers to create a
workload cluster a workload cluster
being a cluster that we intend to run
our actual services on not the
management cluster but it is a cluster
that is managed by
our management cluster
so as you can see from this whole
process from the common issues that i
mentioned in the very beginning of this
things like server power management and
server life cycle management are
entirely handled by cedaro metal
sederal metal knows when a machine
should be turned on it knows when it
should be turned off and in the case
that someone accidentally turns it off
it knows that the
desired state is that it's actually to
be turned on so it will go ahead and
turn it on
the life cycle management is also
entirely automated and handled by cedaro
metal sedero metal knows when it needs
to pixie boot
and install talos it also knows when it
needs to actually have this system be
registered with itself
it also knows when
the operating system needs to be removed
and so in that process
what happens is the agent will be sent
back
and will actually
wipe that server and get the disks
prepared so that it becomes the server
becomes um part
becomes available within the pool again
it becomes
clean and unallocated
the fact that we're using talos linux
handles all of the os management that
we're going to need again
our goal with talos is for you to forget
about the operating system and to
deliver kubernetes so we have a secure
hardened
api driven operating system that aims to
basically remove the whole operating
system management out from underneath
you and handle it itself
not only that but kubernetes sorry
excuse me telos linux also handles the
management of kubernetes it's going to
install kubernetes according to the best
practices
and it's going to roll out control plane
changes for you that you submit to talos
linux it knows when you want to perform
an upgrade whether or not ncd
wilser will
survive this upgrade and so we have
safeguards around protecting the
kubernetes data so that whole kubernetes
management what we like to say is we
give you a cloud-like experience but
also giving you that flexibility so
within telos
we have the ability to actually change
and tweak certain parameters within the
control plane
but not so many to where you can shoot
yourself in the foot
and so you can see
a huge portion of that overhead that we
face on bare metal is dramatically
reduced simply from using cedaro metal
and talos linux
the last two things that i listed in the
common issues were networking and
storage
and this is where the cedarolabs team
comes into play we have a wealth of
experience in getting kubernetes running
on bare metal
we know all the patterns we know what
tools to use and we have reference
architectures for different scenarios
so on my host what should i do should i
run you know
routing on the host
how do i do bgp
we also have a feature within talos
which allows you to
basically
do load balancing of the kubernetes
control plane um using a vip which is
handled and managed by
talos itself and so you don't need any
extra infrastructure outside of that you
don't need load balancers for example
now storage rook and maya store work
great with tallows we commonly recommend
this to our customers
rook being the more
battle hardened one in maya store being
one that aligns better with our
philosophy of
making the operating system be less of a
thing
and then finally load balancing a common
thing that we
suggest to our users and customers is to
use metal lb which will allow you to
expose those services
uh specifically sorry the kubernetes
services using bgp or gratuitous arp
so
we know how to
when and how to run these various tools
so that you can get kubernetes running
on bare metal
and so
at the end of the day
we're capable of handling all of the
common issues that i talked about in the
beginning
and if you want to learn more
you can reach us at cedarolabs.com
if you want to check out the project
specific sites around cedar metal and
talos linux you can go to sedero.dev or
talos.dev
and now i will pause for some questions
i see we have a question already
the first question is can you manage
multiple clusters this way
the short answer is yes you can answer
you can absolutely do more than one
cluster this way in fact that's why we
built this
we wanted to
make managing bare metal clusters
easy reproducible
and you can kind of print these clusters
out within your data center
i should also add that since cl sedero
metal is built on top of cluster api not
only can you create multiple clusters
this way but you can use this same
management cluster to say create
kubernetes clusters within aws
gcp
azure
digitalocean
equinix metal and wherever there is a
supported
cluster api infrastructure provider
question i saw your release of kubespan
does sedero metal work with kubespan
currently
not yet but the way that sedero metal
works is it's it's a bootstrapping
system which we are also working on
making it
more dynamic for the life cycle of the
cluster but you get the cluster up and
running and then from then what you
could do is you can actually enable
kubespan using our apis since talos is
api driven
you can you know script this all out in
a very dependable way
simply enable it with an api call
and you can set this up
manually but we are working on
integrating this with sedum metal in a
much more seamless and automated way
okay next question what happens when you
remove a machine from a cluster ah good
question i don't think i went over that
so
what happens is
sedero metal knows that now that this
machine is deleted this machine if you
remember from the demo is associated
with the metal machine which is
then associated with the server you saw
that in the server binding
we know that the machine has been
deleted and so that we now know that the
server
has to be cleaned up
and so
since cedero metal does the
power management of this physical
machine we
basically tell the machine to pixie boot
on the next boot
power cycle it
send back our agent to
the server
server boots that and then the agent
knows i need to clean up all these disks
and get this node prepped
so that it can become available again
for the next cluster
and so
it's simple as that really
i'll give just a moment for maybe
another question to come through
okay
great well thank you everyone i
appreciate everyone showing up that was
a lot of fun i hope that you learned a
lot about how you can do
bare metal kubernetes using cedar metal
take care